sometimes watching the beeping isn't
enough you also want to eat that lately
that's why there's movie recipe you're
now going to be officially interviewed
should I go light the candle first sir
what no today we're with chef Gerry
class gala at Aria in Atlanta Georgia
we've challenged him with making a dish
Fitz to be served at the grand Budapest
hotel during its heyday chef cloyce
Khanna has selected a list of essential
ingredients to make it happen
they are caraway seeds it's an important
spice in Eastern European cuisine
arsenic it's as similar to a potato as
the grand Budapest hotel is to a normal
movie think about it and Hungarian sweet
paprika this one should be
self-explanatory it's because Wes
Anderson is a super sweet guy let's get
cooking no grand Budapest hotel when we
think of 2014 movie Wes Anderson it's
charming
it was nominated for Best Picture it was
and not one of my favorite Wes Anderson
movies but really enjoyable extremely
enjoyable he's always a visual
storyteller but I think this is probably
where he put it into just another gear
like there's so many little details tons
of detail yeah watching a Wes Anderson
field is always a delight for your eyes
right even like the the ones where the
characters meant I connect to you as
much there's always so much going on
visually and it's so charming and ray
Fiennes I've never seen him like this
yeah in any movie goes for his way from
nails it yeah I mean he's way out there
in this performance but he had to be
right to sort of anchor the film
[Music]
the other thing about this is everybody
is in this movie
oh geez I mean anybody that's ever
worked with them before is made their
way in Schwartzman's in is Jeff Goldblum
and F Murray Abraham again telling a
story to a young listener like I may be
the evidence
yeah that's the other thing about this
movie that there is there are so many
big names in it it almost is a little
disappointing that they couldn't be used
more right especially Jason Schwartzman
we were talking about is like hey you
want to come by I don't sit and play
this role because it's basically
meaningless and it has three line yeah
I'll do anything for us and so when I
see some of these people on screen I
want to see them more for longer but you
know that's hardly a major gripe yeah
[Music]
so a dish based on the grand Budapest
hotel my first reaction is it's probably
going to be symmetrical we're really
colorful yeah very symmetrical I'm also
assuming it's probably not like a baked
good of some sort like your cakes that
are prominent in this even though that's
part of the story I don't think it's
going to be that he may draw inspiration
from Budapest and I don't know what kind
of food they eat in Budapest yeah but
you know maybe a regional thing yeah
well maybe when I do have some dinner at
the beginning of it Murray Abraham has a
lamb he does of something that's
something that would be very interesting
yeah so it was like a lamb what was it
lamb I can't remember it was a lamb some
lamb dish ragu was it a lamb ragu
[Music]
I like what I see so far oh my goodness
oh no that's gorgeous oh you look like
those Hardy eating guides what do we
have here
well we had a little inspiration of
course you know the movie you know grand
Budapest hotel you know so my mind goes
right to that part of Eastern Europe and
one of my favorite dishes to cook with
cool weather hits is goulash and so what
we're doing is a Hungarian beef goulash
I've got a little twist on it
goulash can need to be a soup or a stew
I've taken it more stew like and we're
doing it with just buttered noodles and
a little creme fraiche well so you know
the big thing with goulash of the
flavors yet have great Hungarian sweet
paprika well listen I want you to taste
while it's still hot sounds great let's
dive in yeah absolutely
are these potatoes we these are
yellowfin potatoes or Yukon Golds what
you'll notice with those potatoes versus
choosing russets is that russets will
get crumbly these are waxy potatoes so
they're going to hold a shape I can
taste the sweetness you're talking about
yeah the paprika and also the you know
we had traditionally you may not see
tomatoes and goulash I choose tomatoes
for the sweetness and the acidity so it
makes the dish a little more interesting
but then of course the garlic lots of
onions and then just the slow cook to
get the beef nice and tender and then
the finished seasoning of course is we
toast caraway seeds and then we pop them
in a spice mill and pulverize those
tournament oak powder and then we season
the goulash with the caraway so you got
this wonderful background note it makes
it interesting oh my god I don't want to
stop here so so what's your favorite
part of the movies do you think you know
I just love the characters you know this
yeah this bedroom is just littered with
great characters but you know zero is my
hero
yeah you know when he just says who
wouldn't want to work at the grand
budapest hotel right if I you know it's
a given you know that you're going to be
the lobby boy yeah you know and then
registering so I just love this
character the characterization if you're
a fan of Wes Anderson like I am you know
it's really a great movie making it has
a kind of old-school a meanness to it
you know which doesn't take itself too
seriously yeah but the acting is
first-class and the set design is
first-class and obviously who doesn't
want to work with Wes Anderson yeah yeah
everybody everybody and it looks like it
in that movie everybody did yeah we were
rattling off all the cast a lot of lot
of name actors in the movie and she
always know when you're watching a Wes
Anderson films yeah he's got he's got
more of a working Asst a quirky nough
stand really anybody else that's his own
you know the signature it's funny to me
how the characters in his movies can be
all over the place and zany even while
the visuals of the film you're watching
are so precise and bland and like
perfectly centered it's just interesting
to me the way he chooses to play those
things although because yeah everything
in everything in the background and and
just ancillary to the room to the thing
that he's framing has its own story to
it it's got its own it adds extra detail
to the characters and what's going on
and everything and he does this I think
he does this most in this movie oh yeah
every everything has a place in the
background yeah oh man this was really
good well glassing village right yeah I
can tell how much we didn't like it
[Music]